many a culture is home to a mythical
beast an elusive creature that thrives
in the imagination if not verifiable
reality the Scots have Nessie
monstrously hiding in its highland lock
Nepal has the abominably unverified Yeti
even New Jersey has its own devil
roaming the Pine Barrens hell-bent on
scaring the bejesus out of unsuspecting
campers and here in majestic Iceland
there aren't the elves who you really
don't want to cross especially if you
happen to be into sub-arctic tunnel
construction why are you saying that
this project is running two years late
possibly absolutely because of owls hmm
the look of a journalist trying to
remain open-minded surely the government
body overseeing Iceland's infrastructure
projects can't take all of this elf
Roberge seriously as a government policy
or possibly government custom to take
into account potential elf habitation
when putting in roads and that sort of
thing we are not going to look at a line
for a road don't think maybe their heirs
there or they were there it's it's more
like if something comes up and come up
it has in 2013 the government allowed a
new road to be delayed by apparently
invisible elves inside one giant rock
Alice's after the Earl's gave permission
yeah i mean our lady who told us that
this was probably a chapel and there
were alps living there she said belief
in unseen rock dwelling elves has been
around since the Vikings arrived in this
country over a thousand years ago
apparently Norse beliefs die hard
because an elf lady and taxpayer kronor
to move a 70 ton Boulder is no big deal
in this Icelandic government department
it's nice to sort of think about hidden
people covering in the rocks and
everywhere
I mean it would be really really nice if
they were there